here's a quick demo example in this case
let's say you're respons for paying
invoices and you get your plumbing
invoice you fire up a debt that pulls up
the invoice it's all being done by the
model right now pulls up the invoice
reads the pixels in this PDF realizes
what it's about stores some interesting
facts about this and then pulls up quick
books and then correctly enters who is
the pay right Savant plumbers like how
did you pay what category is this like
and it realizes the category was never
written in the PDF but it realizes a
plumbing invoice so it should go into
repairs and maintenance this task that
you probably would have had to do like
10 or 20 times a day for your job you
show Adept how to do it once and now
every time you get a new email invoice
uh you just fire up Adept and it handles
this task for
you